[Music]
on this tuesday night the political pact
to keep the liberals in power
the big deal we saw an ability to work
together with the new democrats we're
not going to let the liberals off the
hook what could end the agreement why
it's not a coalition and what's in it
for the ndp
a ukrainian psychiatric hospital bombed
and the fresh please from president
zielenski distressing deja vu
this time it's the russian nazis doing
the attacking the history of one
ukrainian city's hiding spots during war
plus deadly tornadoes oh my god a car
tear through the southern us all right
run run run
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jackson proskow
you're looking at parliament hill where
today the minority government of prime
minister justin trudeau may have just
locked up power for the next three years
hi there and thanks for joining us
almost six months to the day after
canadians denied trudeau a majority the
liberals have reached an agreement with
the ndp that could avoid another
election until at least 2025.
the so-called confidence and supply deal
is not a formal coalition and the
liberals are not power sharing but if it
holds new democrats will prop up the
government in exchange for support of
key ndp priorities the opposition calls
it all a power grab and this deal could
have major implications for all of
canada's political parties we'll have
more on that in just a moment but first
abigail beeman breaks down the deal and
what it means for canadians
my question to the leader of the new ndp
liberal party this coalition is once
again raising the carbon tax a raucous
question period with no end of jabs
about the new ndp liberal deal now with
the ndp liberal marriage
they're more uneasy than ever prime
minister justin trudeau says it's about
stability the liberals will have ndp
support on confidence votes including
for the next four budgets i thought
long and hard about this it was not an
easy decision
with so much instability around us
canadians need stability this is not a
coalition we never intended it to be a
coalition not a coalition because new
democrats don't get any seats at the
cabinet table so what do they get the
seven-point deal covers lots of mutual
liberal and ndp ground affordable
housing reconciliation climate change
with several promises for the ndp free
dental care as early as this year for
low-income children and a commitment to
move on 10 paid sick days as fast as
possible in 2022 there will be an
oversight group of staff and politicians
that meet monthly to take stock of the
deal with quarterly meetings between
trudeau and ndp leader jugmeet singh and
if things go wrong if they fall short on
what we've agreed to then then the deal
doesn't continue the prime minister took
pains to reassure critics parliament
will function as normal with debate and
disagreement top of mind already the
ndp's reticence to increase defense
spending as war rages in ukraine in the
areas where there is not agreement we
will continue to do the things that the
liberal party
was elected to do and
we'll look for support from other
parties now let me be clear this is
nothing more than a justin trudeau
power grab the other opposition parties
sound the alarm bells it means the
decimation of canadian oil and gas in
lng that means that that is really a way
to prop up putin and russia it's a false
majority if this deal holds the justin
trudeau liberal minority government will
be in power for almost as long as if
they had won a majority in the last
election jackson
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks abigail
it's clear justin trudeau has just been
handed a political lifeline at a time
when the conservatives are looking for a
new leader and new democrats still have
little chance of forming a government as
eric sorensen reports the liberals now
have a rare opportunity
no joint appearance no handshake neither
justin trudeau nor jugmeet singh wants
the optics of a coalition but there is a
new togetherness not just on legislation
but a wish to avoid another election
anytime soon the government
can function with predictability and
stability stability in particular for a
prime minister who came to office seven
years ago in the next two years the
economy could slump his government could
fall his own party could grow restless
with his leadership this agreement
relieves all those pressure points for
now this certainly does set the stage
for the liberals to have a bit more time
to allow the prime minister perhaps to
resign in a year or so and then they
could have their own leadership race and
allow the new leader to
set the agenda for the party for the
federal ndp it's a practical recognition
that it's never won an election but has
influenced major change tommy douglas on
universal health care jack leighton's
role in affordable housing but as a
junior partner in this agreement the
risk is jugmeet singh will not get
credit at election time electorally it
probably would have been safer just to
keep on fighting and and maybe fight
every step of the way they could lose
their identity i mean the problem for
the smaller party when you get into one
of these arrangements is that it's
fairly easy for voters to forget that
you were there to provide that support
for conservatives who've lost the last
three elections under three different
leaders the party now loses the
opportunity to bring down a minority
government early but it does allow them
to distinguish themselves more clearly
from the liberal ndp combo canadians can
count on conservatives to be
consistently conservative
we are the party of less government
spending we are the party of low taxes
and it will give a new conservative
leader time to rebuild the government in
waiting i think there's going to be a
clear picture of contrast to be painted
when the next election comes i think
you're going to find there'll be blue
liberals
who will be frustrated with the
arrangement that was made today and the
conservatives need to find ways to court
them the prime minister says he will run
again i'm planning on continuing to
serve canadians through and beyond the
next election but that is now far in the
future the pressure and unpredictability
of a minority government has been
diffused for up to three years a
lifetime in politics eric sorenson
global news
the federal government avoided having to
intervene in the labor dispute between
cp rail and the union representing its
workers the two sides say they've agreed
to binding arbitration ending a two-day
work stoppage as of noon today cp's
three thousand conductors engineers
train and yard workers were back on the
job the teamsters canada rail conference
says wages and pensions are still
stumbling blocks but its negotiators
were able to reach terms and conditions
in the best interests of its members
cp says it's aiming to resume normal
train operations as soon as possible
and after a busy day on the domestic
front the prime minister is flying to
brussels tonight ahead of meetings with
allied countries about the attack on
ukraine our david aiken is traveling
with prime minister trudeau and joins us
now with a look at what's ahead on this
trip david
jackson the prime minister is going to
spend the next two days in europe in
brussels meeting with world leaders
tomorrow wednesday he's going to speak
to the european parliament and that's a
rare honor for a canadian prime minister
right now the european parliament is
seized with the issue of food security
russia and ukraine are two of the
world's biggest food producers and food
exporters and if ukraine farmers can't
put their crops in the ground this
spring that has all sorts of
implications for food security not just
in europe but also in african countries
and elsewhere in the world so a lot of
people may look to canada to help canada
can be a bread basket to the world good
thing we got that cp rail work stoppage
sorted out so canadian farmers can put
their crops in the ground so the pm
we'll talk about that then on thursday
the prime minister joins nato leaders
for a nato heads of government summit
one of the issues there is nato unity
nato consensus in the face of russian
aggression some nato countries want to
move a little quicker poland for example
would like to put peacekeeping troops
into ukraine uh lithuania would like to
enforce a no-fly zone canada and other
nato leaders aren't there yet but they
will be talking about that after the
nato summit g7 leaders will meet that
includes the canadian prime minister on
the on the agenda the global economy how
to respond to china and after that the
pm gets back in his plane and heads
right back here to ottawa jackson all
right david aiken at ottawa
international airport thanks david
ukrainian president zielinski spoke to
prime minister trudeau today he tweeted
they discussed the humanitarian
catastrophe the peace process and the
importance of effective security for
ukraine zielinski also told pope francis
he would welcome the vatican's help to
mediate peace talks with russia and when
he spoke to italian lawmakers today the
ukrainian president warned his country
is putin's gateway to europe ukrainian
forces are holding back some of russia's
ground offensive but hundreds of
thousands of people are still trapped
and desperate to leave redmond shannon
reports
dr anatoly pavlov is filming what's left
of his mikolai of hospital
i want to cry he says in russian his
first language because we had a
connection between ukraine and russia
but russian cruelty is so brutal
nowhere is the cruelty greater than in
the besieged city of maryupo ukrainian
authorities say two more large bombs
were dropped tuesday and at least one
hundred thousand people want to leave
but can't
the mayor of melitopol says like
mariupol his residents are also running
out of food and medicine
similar supply struggles reported in
occupied harsan where russian troops
again allegedly used stun grenades to
break up protests
rome the latest virtual venue for
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
describing his country as russia's
gateway to europe
he pleaded with italian lawmakers for a
complete european ban on russian oil and
gas imports
the white house suggesting the eu and
u.s president joe biden will make
further commitments in europe this week
he will announce joint action on
enhancing european energy security and
reducing europe's dependence on russian
gas at long last now
zielinski has told ukrainian media he is
prepared to meet with his russian
counterpart vladimir putin u.n secretary
general antonia guterres imploring
russia to make that happen and to stop
its invasion
continuing the war in ukraine
is morally unacceptable
politically indefensible and militarily
nonsensical
there is enough on the table to seize
hostilities now
and seriously negotiate now the kremlin
said tuesday it would like the ongoing
talks between teams from russia and
ukraine to be more active and
substantive but it refuses to make
public the demands it's making
jackson redmond shannon in london thanks
redmond the united nations secretary
general says the war in ukraine is
unwinnable and going nowhere fast
the only outcome to all these is more
suffering more destruction
and more horror as far as the eye can
see
ukrainian people are enduring a living
hell
the un secretary general says the war is
reverberating globally with skyrocketing
food energy and fertilizer prices
threatening to spiral into a global
hunger crisis
an even longer punishment for putin's
fiercest critic
coming up the new prison sentence for
alexi navalny
a russian court has convicted vladimir
putin's number one critic alexei navalny
on fraud charges and sentenced him to
nine years in a maximum security prison
a gaunt-looking navalny appeared in a
makeshift courtroom today at a penal
colony outside moscow he was already
serving two and a half years of a
sentence for probation violations the
45-year-old opposition leader says all
of the charges against him are
politically motivated navalny was
arrested in february 2021 after
returning to russia from germany where
he was recovering from a nerve agent
attack that he blames on putin and
russian security services
and russia hardened its so-called fake
news laws today to crack down on dissent
and punish citizens protesting the war
in ukraine
thousands have already been detained in
anti-war demonstrations across russia
now any citizen who knowingly spreads
so-called false information about any
russian state operations abroad faces
fines of 1.5 million rubles that's
roughly 17 thousand dollars canadian and
up to 15 years in prison
and in ukraine russian troops have now
moved into residential areas outside the
key port city of odessa tonight
ukrainian officials are accusing russia
of striking civilian homes
until now odessa had largely been spared
from the russian invasion but ukraine's
third largest city has a history of
fighting foreign invaders during world
war ii ukraine was attacked and occupied
by the nazis those horrors shaped the
history of odessa and created a special
relationship with another port city a
world away in canada
jeff semple reports from odessa
the ukrainian port city of odessa is on
russia's war path if and when the
russian army attacks odessa's residents
will have plenty of places to hide
beneath ukraine's third largest city
lies a labyrinth
these are just some of the 1 000
entrances leading down to one of the
world's largest networks of tunnels
dating back to the 1800s when they were
mined for limestone the tunnels have
just been reopened for a much different
purpose
when we hear the air raid sirens
everyone comes down here we've tried to
make it as comfortable as possible says
this doctor who works nearby
it's not the first time these bunkers
have been converted to bomb shelters
when nazi germany invaded the soviet
union in 1941 odessa was one of its
first targets
the city fought back for 73 days and
inflicted significant casualties before
finally falling to the nazis
for their bravery soviet leader joseph
stalin later proclaimed odessa hero city
that name is still written on the main
train station where thousands are now
fleeing war once again
images from the city in 1941 look eerily
similar to today
history repeats itself this local
historian says but this time it's the
russian nazis doing the attacking he
shows us letters and diaries from the
second world war written by ukrainian
soldiers and their families
now this historian is writing his own
war diary
the situation is horrible my wife and
children have left the country he says
i'm ready to pick up a gun and fight
this ukrainian canadian was just three
years old in 1942 his earliest childhood
memory is hiding in a bunker and hearing
the bombs all the lights went off it was
a
terrible thud that bomb had just fallen
near the
bunker his family eventually escaped
ukraine and fled to canada after
odessa's liberation in 1944 the city of
vancouver officially proclaimed odessa
its first sister city and sent
desperately needed humanitarian aid
they're very similar vancouver has a
port odessa has support
vancouver is vibrant odessa is very
vibrant on tuesday the mayors of
vancouver and odessa spoke by phone the
canadian city once again offering its
support in a time of war vancouver city
hall lighting up in ukrainian blue and
yellow but unlike during the second
world war this time western countries
are not mobilizing their militaries to
help
it's just disastrous it's a slaughter of
ukrainian people and
devastation of ukraine
jeff sample global news odessa
well just ahead the pickup that got
picked up as tornadoes roared across
texas
well check out the heart-pounding moment
a pickup truck was swept up in a tornado
it flipped and went spinning but then
look at this it lands back on its wheels
and manages to drive away
all that flying debris is from a nearby
mobile home more than 20 tornadoes left
a trail of destruction across north and
central texas and oklahoma overnight
causing extensive damage to homes and
schools one person is dead and many
others are injured
rainfall from that same storm also hit
other parts of texas where it offered a
reprieve from a slew of wildfires
more than 170 fires had burned across
the state over the past week torching
dozens of buildings firefighters are
making progress with the largest fires
near fort worth 60 contained though
heavy winds continue to complicate their
efforts in drier areas
well next the struggles ahead for
millions of civilians who have fled the
war in ukraine
the ukrainian refugee crisis is about to
surpass worst case predictions nearly 4
million people have fled and thousands
still cross into neighboring countries
every single day
the sheer numbers are just one of the
challenges for governments across europe
as mike armstrong reports from poland
those fleeing can't simply leave behind
the trauma of war
there is a difference between the waves
of refugees flowing out of ukraine now
and the ones that left early on there
isn't just the trauma of leaving their
homes that would be enough but for those
leaving in what is week four many
toughed it out and now know what it
means to live in cities under siege
this woman says between the bombings and
not knowing how it'll end it was too
scary to stay she took her child but
left her husband and mother behind
the world health organization is warning
many people fleeing ukraine need more
than just food and shelter there are
basic health issues many arrive at
border crossings after traveling for
days without proper food or water there
are also problems caused by distress the
who representative for poland says in
this country about 30 000 refugees have
severe mental diseases but there's still
a much bigger number dealing with trauma
with the number of refugees now about
half a million require support for
mental health disorders due to the
conflict
the challenges for a country like poland
are massive the vast majority of
refugees are women and children
shelter's just one problem among many
the minister of education says the
country's school system is adding about
10 000 students a day the u.n predicted
and planned for up to four million
refugees leaving ukraine they're likely
to blow by that number by the weekend we
don't plan to put out a new planning
figure
but of course we're ready to react
now the numbers crossing each day have
dropped this polish train station near
the border was packed a week ago things
have slowed down but the mayor says
they're still getting about 8 000
refugees going through his city each day
and helping them through he calls a
marathon after one month and a lot other
people is very tired so we have to think
about next months or maybe hopefully not
but maybe
about years
that lack of a timeline is one of the
issues for refugees as well they're
living a marathon and have no way of
knowing where or when it ends
mike armstrong global news cheshire
poland
and that's global national for this
tuesday night i'm jackson prosko as the
war continues life goes on in ukraine
and in some cases it begins we leave you
with glimpses of that tonight the city
of kiev shared these photos monday
showing newborns with their mothers at a
maternity ward and since the invasion
began city officials say 807 new
children have been born in the capital
thanks for watching we hope to see you
again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]